last night
in the nightcap to the third monday
night doubleheader of the season and i
have a feeling there will be more
cardinals beat the cowboys 38 to 10.
dallas has given up 218 points through
six games that's the most in the nfl
since 1970 and now it's starting even
though they're in first place in the
worst division in football maybe the
worst division we've ever seen in
football unnamed cowboys according to
jane slater the embedded cowboys
reporter employed by the league
partially employed by the cowboys
themselves let's call it what it is she
put this on twitter today do we have the
tweet because i don't have the language
of it in front of me but i can summarize
while we get up oh there it is cowboys
players initially bought into keeping
things internal now as they sit two and
four the discontent is leaking out on
the coaching staff quote totally
unprepared they don't teach they don't
have any sense of adjusting on the fly
another quote they just aren't good at
their jobs end quote now here's the
question in dallas is it the players not
very good is it the coaches not getting
much out of the players and usually this
sets up shireen conflict between coach
who says the players stink and gm who
says players are fine you stink
in dallas the dynamic's different
because gm is owner and in a roundabout
way and i'm not going to suggest that
the cowboys gave the nod to this report
from the media company they partially
own i'm not suggesting they planted this
report with the media company they
partially own all i'm saying is this
in the grand scheme of things it
actually helps jerry and stephen jones
for this to be out there because
it shines the negative light on the
coaching staff and it takes some of the
heat off of them for rounding up a bunch
of players who just aren't good enough
mike this is when you really miss the
way it used to be right
i went to the game and normally you
would go down and you would get jerry
jones and i guarantee you he would have
said something that made news
and those questions would have come up
how much confidence do you have in this
coaching staff that would have been one
of the first questions because they
don't look prepared i don't care what
you say where they are aren't whether
the all-season affected them or not
whatever
this does not look like a prepared
football team and
besides giving up all those points
they're also their turnover ratio is the
highest
or lowest or however you want to phrase
it they're minus 12 and it's the worst
uh since the merger at this point in the
season they're just doing some bad
things things that bad football teams do
whether it's coaching whether it's a
players whatever and you can point to
dak all you want
but look he's only missed one game and
so you can't spin all this and say well
it's the absence of dak and i know they
have some
a ton of other injuries especially on
the offensive line i get that this
defense is awful and there's so many
awful things about this team and you do
wonder is it coaching is it personnel is
it both this is a bad football team
right now and they're still in first
place in the nfc east which tells you
all you want to know about that division
i have a feeling it's both and i have a
feeling it's going to continue and chris
sims and i talked about this today i
think it's going to be
philadelphia or washington that ends up
winning this division washington if they
go with alex smith otherwise
philadelphia has shown us the past
couple of years they'll start slowly
they'll figure it out they get some guys
healthy or they don't as what happened
last year was carson wentz and a bunch
of no names that found a way to close
from five and seven to nine and seven
and win the division but the cowboys are
definitely moving in the wrong direction
even though shireen they're in first
place i don't think it's gonna last
unless they start figuring things out
very quickly
and what i found interesting last night
listen to mike mccarthy he said i'm
still figuring out my team
really at this point in the season i
mean i realize you didn't have an off
season program but how are you still
figuring out your team and what they do
well you should know this by now you had
six weeks of practice and you've had six
games how do you not know what your team
is good at and what they're capable of i
i just i found that very curious last
night listening to him say that
yeah and uh look the problem is it's
meshing with some of the criticisms of
mccarthy's time in green bay the things
that trickled out after he left those
same issues now rearing their ugly head
in dallas and we'll see whether or not
the cowboys can turn it around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports